irgendwann kam es dann halt dazu dass
luca auf einmal sich zu den kopf
gehalten hat und so zu mir gemeint ja
mir irgendwas gegen kopf getroffen wird
schwarz vor augen und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen und minecraft
video
wir spielen heute in time auf simulator
setzen hob i can make it in time und
leute mich hat es voll erwischt ich bin
gerade einfach eingepennt werden max ist
ein video aufgenommen hat überschlafen
warum werde ich euch gleich mal erzählen
ist gestern richtig richtig krasse nacht
und lutz kommt auch vor phuket jetzt
wurde das dings aktiviert sich so
schnell es geht
die grace zu sehen ist schon vorbei ist
mir richtig richtig schnell weil einer
der zeitung ganz schön aktiviert hat und
zwar ja das ist eine richtig witzige
geschichte ich habe wo man lange um
vorne aus anzufangen auszufallen
die habe ihm porsche- mein bester freund
wirst aber immer derselbe
gute hier hat läuft immer daran und ist
immer einer da drüben hände ja meistens
schon also die spanne reicht hier eine
steht da oben einer mal hängt einer
verhängt leute die sache war ich hab mir
den scheichs erlös gesucht obwohl ich
ihn so sehr hassen
und als allererstes ging es mal so los
dass ich am 13.5
das heißt gestern mit das video seht zu
ihm hoch gefahren bin
das ist eigentlich eine strecke von
fünfeinhalb stunden
aber weil so richtig viele mitarbeiten
anders als für youtube und sich dann
gedacht haben ihre feiertage machen
verlängertes wochenende war einfach so
krass viel los auf den screens man ich
kenne das aus der holt das führt uns
geht's los ist aber so viel war da ist
es auf jeden fall selten es ist ab ist
es selten und ich hab einfach natürlich
stecke achteinhalb stunden gebraucht ich
habe zwar eine mitfahrerin
mitfahrgelegenheit die bahn ice ich hab
gesagt ich hab gesagt bringt uns jetzt
gebracht ja hab ich dir erzählt ok
dessen insider leute war auf jeden fall
heavy ich bin ein achteinhalb stunden
gefahren
achteinhalb stunden saß am steuer und
habe dementsprechend gelitten in der
hitze man auch keine klimaanlage doch
selber gelitten ich hab selber immerhin
alter konsequent nichts für dich ja für
mich das eine menge max os x steht für
mich seid nicht so und dann kam ich
gestern abend nachts um elf bei lokalen
und luca gerade noch aufgenommen und so
und dann haben wir beide noch geduscht
dann sind wir los gegangen erst noch
einmal abgetrieben
wir haben ja wir haben es getrieben was
denn hier konsumiert ist nicht nur
zusammen christmas alter dort wenn du es
wenn die leute herausfinden
das ist auch christmas gibt wir sind
aufgeschmissen wir auf wir wissen
aufgeschmissen wie achtlos an ganz ohne
klamotten
warum funktioniert der trick er ist lag
nicht einmal warum lässt du es nicht
doch ist locker lag seit black ist liga
oder was ist da los
der trecker funktioniert nicht muss ja
eigentlich denken mir vergeht nicht aber
deutlich wie verzichten muss was
wichtiges erfolgt skf instagram dynamik
ist irgendwie beschreiben bei der fast
10.000 jobs und er will nie so penetrant
sagen dass ihr folge wird aber folgt ihm
alle jeder einzelne instagram hatten das
video sieben nicht verklebt auf den
griffel und folgt dem jo und schreibt
noch max in die kommentare geben nicht
blocken
ich bin da ist ein namens kind war auch
locker
nein sie hat sich selbst viel geld
jetzt wollte geld für tnt spamming so
nice ja leute dann haben wir abends um
elf sind wir angekommen über beide
geduscht und was zu essen geholt und
dann hier noch links ein bisserl immer
dann sind wir gestalten
luz hat nach wien geschickt weil er noch
auto fahren musste
bronze diese längst leid es tut mir leid
ich gestorben bin aber ich will die
geschichte weitererzählen deswegen haben
wir mal dran ihr lassen ich bin übrigens
ein turner donath academy unter dem
namen der der der ewige donath ist der
rechtshänder komischer patrick banking
verständlich was anfangs wird vom
zuspruch
diese ganze team ok battle rap ist
battle rap ist etwas für sehr sehr sehr
sehr schön kommentare komplexen wo ich
mich zu diesem diskurs habe in dem video
man hat mir an die conversion alter du
scheiße minecraft und in klammern auch
noch let's play passt ja sowieso keine
ahnung von rap von vom battle rap und
sowas und mach lieber deine videos
weiter oder sowas schreibt er einfach
vollkommene scheiße
dann darf ich habe recht gegner sehr gut
mitgekommen und genau die sind ja nicht
anders
warum erfolgt ja klar ist schon dass ich
hier folgten einer ja leute haben ja was
du erstmal zu trinken holen sind
losgegangen so komm schon
ja was hatte ich mir
warum halloween special wie die sie
angreifen
diesfeld skinny leute teams verboten
hast gesehen im sony angegriffen
doch dann habe ich angriff jetzt habe
ich noch eine chance bekommen an das ist
und teilweise ist nichts für mich
überhaupt nicht zum gospel ja leute dann
sind wir da losgegangen
und dann ging es los da im club es ging
richtig richtig rund also da wurde
geprobt
die wall of death also wie bisher wohl
auch depp ist dass sich dass die
menschenmasse so teilt und dann beim
drop rennt man halt auch wenn man dazu
und so es war richtig krank
es war richtig richtig sich dieser abend
der lüge zu forschen naja und dann nutzt
kommt später noch an der geschichte
einmalig so vorschnell okay dann viel
besser ich glaube im namen
was ist wenn dir das nicht kannst du
beide wechseln wir müssen richtig da und
seien weiter
meinst du der anderen gern von
direct-date combo gerade du bist die
turn und junge ich hab' ich bin der
eternal donath haben die ich gehabt die
könnten den ewigen kammer und dann wie
gesagt da wiederum geburt ist es richtig
richtig eskaliert es war da drin war wie
in der sauna alles nur um gesprungen und
alt ultra stick war auch unser lieblings
der von mir luca deswegen wir haben auch
voll abgegangen drauf und irgendwann kam
es dann halt dazu dass luca auf einmal
sich den kopf gehalten hat und so zu mir
gemeint ja-mehrheit mir irgendwas gegen
kopf getroffen wird schwarz vor augen
und ich soll ja was ist los und habe
erst gedacht ja lutz macht irgendwie
spaß und ich hoffe natürlich dass er
deswegen habe ich erst mal nichts
gemacht und erst dann raus gegangen und
dann nein das klingt jetzt doof aber ich
mache keinen unterschied aber okay
ja und dann im nachhinein hatte mir so
erzählt das ist dass er irgendwie voll
ausgeknockt wurde dass er wohl irgendwie
beim pogen ausgerutscht ist ich hoffe
wieder funktionieren jetzt warum auch
die distanz fertigmachen gezeigt haben
sie das gefühl dass er beim pogen im wie
rausgerutscht ist dann hingefallen ist
und als er gerade unten war wohl
irgendwie so zac knie gegen den kopf
bekommen
das war richtig weil schon mal richtig
heftig gemeint hätten die
gehirnerschütterung und ich habe mir
eine nachricht geschickt wäre nämlich
eine gruppe die heute wir hatten
wirklich wirklich wir haben ja dann
haben wir halt teppich hinein geschickt
hat es hinein geschickt
natürlich testen einschicken im jahr und
wir haben gelacht ich wünsche es war
eine freude uns allen
es war eine freude uns allen weh erzählt
auch in wirklichkeit ist
nein doch in wirklichkeit ist echt allen
eine freude
okay ich habe ihn ja mit ihm aufgenommen
und er hat recht haben sie hält am beach
ist überzeugt in der kompass sind aber
ich muss man endlich habe ich mal mit
rechtsklick updaten aber auf jeden fall
schade dass man die spieler in ferne
nicht mal gezeigt bekommen das war
richtig nach vorne
der bau ist am hacken
es hat der trader sei richtig krass aus
aber das sagt voll nach hacks aus oder
junge naja gut vielleicht war es ja doch
kein hacker oder der mannschaft meine
kommentare das wetter gehalten hat bei
den ersten moment sagt für mich volle
kanne aus bisschen später nicht mehr
getroffen
egal ob eure meinung in die kommentare
zum heer weiter
der abend ist er noch richtig eskaliert
also wer ewig unterwegs
bis um vier in dem laden halte auch in
anderen bis zum 6 da habt ihr drei
stunden geschlafen hat beide
gewissenhaftigkeit machen dann haben wir
alle sehr wenig geschlafen und dann sind
wir am nächsten tag in andere richtung
losgefahren mit dem auto und ja so
schließt sich der kreis
wir haben uns dann ich habe mich dann
hier zu meiner familie gefahren zumal
meine mutter und den rest warte ich
glaube er hat er als auch heute die
schwerter äxte und an weihnachten nicht
dass du mit dem getränke oder doch eher
eine dia schwert richtig gesehen hat hey
ich verstehen was mit den leuten los wo
ihr können die alle ihre dia schwester
also links ist acht minuten währt wenn
du halt die kanzlerin steht vielleicht
ja könnte sein
es wird auf jeden fall knacke gegen ihn
zu kämpfen oder kämpfen die anderen
beiden ja und der kreis schließt sich
damit heute was ich noch sagen wollte
dass ich dann hier zu meiner familie
gefahren bin
dann wissen gecheckt und jetzt hat max
kader aufgenommen und mich hat der
schlaf erwischt der einer der
schlafmangel gekippt und ja dann bin ich
jetzt gerade darum gegangen autos können
zugehört was es geht was war das
ich weiß nicht was ist los alter dem auf
jeden fall mit ein kleines heck
update-server reingemacht what the [ __ ]
mann na ja auf jeden fall
knackig rund 200 sehr witzige story los
ich freue mich sehr dass du ko gegangen
bist du wolltest
dursti nicht reden hab ich es nicht mag
in 99 jetzt möchte ich es nicht mehr als
würde ich dich nicht mehr haben wollen
okay wir müssen es klang als würde man
mich in einer abwasseranlage einführen
die die lage wird eskalieren als würde
man seine größe einstellen
ich habe schon okay heute 3000
wir sehen uns